du jour on va parler de ce fléo dont
tout le monde parle en ce moment on ne
parle que de ça ce sont les punaises de
lit euh depuis la rentrée c'est un truc
de fou hein c'est devenu une cause
nationale tout le monde en parle le
gouvernement ne parle que de punaise de
lit dans les lits dans les canapés dans
les meuvbles dans les tapis dans les
Sipes investissent même les lieux
publics comme les trains les bus les
écoles les bibliothèques les slipes il y
a quelques jours on avait reçu un expert
sur ce plateau mais cette fois on vouit
avoir le témoignage de quelqu'un qui
avait été victime de punaise de lit
puisque vous le voyez dans les canapé
slip meuble et tapis elles sont partout
on va accueillir Julie qui a vécu un
véritable le calvaire à cause de ses
nuisibles elle va tout nous raconter
juste après sur les punaises de lit bien
sûr qui svent partout bien sûr meuble
canapé slip et ca c'est parti vidéoap
regarde dans les transports dans les
habitations elle semble être absolument
partout en France elles font leur retour
les punaises de lit les punaises de lit
et les punaises de lit alors que
plusieurs vidéos amateurs montrant des
punaises de lit dans les espaces publics
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux la
situation préoccupe certains élus et
inquiète même les États-Unis à moins
d'un des
giio et si l'inquiétude grimpe autant
c'est parce que ces petits insectes qui
ne mesure que 5 à 8 mm et qui se
nourrissent de notre sang peuvent nous
faire vivre un véritable calvaire et
être très compliqué à éradiquer c'est
une calamité si jamais je vois le truc
je pense ça va me dégoûter le témoignage
de Julie qui a vécu un enfer à cause des
punaises de lit ce soir dans
TPMP alors euh
oui bonjour
bonjour Il est en
consultation bonjour Jie bonjour bonjour
Pour commencz rassurez-moi vous n'z plus
de Puna de lit non j'en ai plus quoi
mais c un truc de fou ouais c'était
horrible horrible ouais c'était l'orreur
horrible n avz pas ramené au studio
c'est sûr j'espère pas non non mais sans
rigolz on va par plus je suis sûr de ne
plus en avoir parce que j'ai fait
plusieurs détections canine chez moi
dans ma voiture dans mon cabinet à peu
près partout donc je suis sûr de ne plus
en avoir mais c'était c'était l'horreur
parce que ça c'était dans mon lit alors
comment vous êtes aperçu pour la
première fois que vous aviez des
punaises de lit en vrai je je me
grattais j'avais des des boutons mon
mari avait des boutons mais en fait au
départ on est un peu dans le déniis
parce qu'on se dit que ça peut pas nous
arriver enfin on se lave on est on est
des gens propres bien et et donc c'est
sûr que ça peut pas nous arriver donc
j'en ai eu en janvier dernier et puis en
janvier on se dit ouais c'est un
moustique qui m'a piqué é quand Mme
plusieurs fois moustique en janvier
c'est un peu bizarre mais voilà puis
après on se dit on est allergique aux
Zakariens c'est un peu bizarre aussi
jusqu'à ce qu'on en voit une par terre
qui vous en avez une ah ça y est vous
l'avez vu en fait le matin je me
réveille et la veille j'avais dit à mon
mari écoute je suis sûr qu'on a des
punaises il y a quelque chose mais il
faut savoir que la journée on les voit
pas vraiment donc j'ai soulevé mes
matelas j'ai rien vu mon matelas était
blanc et il y avait rien alors que moi
on m'avait toujours dit quand on a des
punaises on les écrasent la nuit et donc
ça met des taches de sang c'est ça mais
moi j'enavais pas vu donc j'étais sûre
qu'en fait j'en avais pas et un jour je
me réveille et une punaise venait je
pense de me piquer et par terre j'en ai
vu une remplie de sang quoi et donc là
c'était l'horreur mais donc c'était tout
petit non ouais c'est un tout petit peu
plus gros qu'un pou ah ouais ah ouis
ouais oui qu'est-ce qu'il a g vous savez
d'ù vous les avez ramené parce que c'est
extravagant ça c'est invasion subite
ouais je sais je sais que je les ai
ramené mais je je le sais après avoir
fait tout le traitement et après avoir
amené une deuxième détection canine
parce que c'est lui qui me l'a trouvé
dans des valises les valises dans les
valises vous étiez parti où j'étais
parti aux États-Unis States ouais et
apparemment c'est infesté là-bas ça à
Miami Miami ah c'est infesté c'est che
moi tu vois je te dis t jure c'est vrai
ah ouais et ça c'était ça ah ouais
parquet ça se voit quand même c'est un
parquet flottant
bien non c'est non non mais et donc
ouais et donc ça a été non mais quand
vous êtes arrivé vous m'avez dit j'ai
vécu un véritable cauchemar ouais
c'était c'était l'horreur parce qu'en
fait on se dit que on on va on peut pas
le dire aux gens parce que on se sent
pas bien alors moi j'ai pris par contre
comment ça le le le pli de de le dire à
tout le monde parce que j'avais peur de
le de le donner aux autres en fait puis
après moi je je je donc vos amis
voulaient plus vous voir non ça va parce
que j'ai j'ai tout de suite enchaîné
avec des des des détections qui sont
venu j'ai j'ai je suis rentrée dans un
dans un système où j'ai payé quelqu'un
qui est venu pour faire la désinfection
chez moi j'ai jeté mes lits j'ai jeté
mon ma tête de lit j'ai ouais ça coûte
très très cher maintenant très cher très
cher très très cher tout ça ça m'a coûté
très cher et donc de d'éradiquer les les
punaises de lit ça vous a coûté cher
ouais ça c'est mes lit c'est plus ma
chamb vous ah ouais ah ouais ah ouais
ouais ouis en fait tout ce que vous
voyez par terre c'est les sacs parce que
les donc le le premier chien qui est
venu à la maison on a trouvé que dans ma
chambre donc il y a un chien détecteur
de punaise ouais ça c'était tous les
sacs que j'ai envoyé à la surgélation en
fait donc ça ça coûte hyper cher on met
nos affaires dans des sacs qu'on doit
fermer vous AZ pas été chez Picard
directement vous JZ les sacs dans les R
bahouais ouais je sais pas si aurait
accepté maison par faut déménager
l'appartement combienû on peut dire
combien ça coûte ou c'est ça coûte
combien de faire
ça le tout de racheter de racheter mes
matelas de racheter les lits et tout ça
a des congélations tout ça là euh en
tout tout tout ça m'a coûté à peu près
5000 € 5000 € avec le chien avec les
deux chiens ah fallait les acheter he
quoi quoi quoi vous avez quoi c'est vous
qui les deux chiens aussi donc ça les
chiens c'est infaillible ils arrivent
ils sont tout alors le premier chien
franchement il est venu en 15 minutes
mais je savais que j'avais des punaises
parce que j'en avais vu je voulais juste
savoir où est-ce que j'en avais parce
que j'ai surgelé toute ma chambre
d'accord donc mes
chaussureses mon linge de lit mes
vêtements tout tout tout et par contre
j'ai dû laver à la main enfin dans une
dans une laverie avec mon mari on a fait
ça pendant 2 jours tout le reste de la
maison donc tout le linge de tous mes
enfants tout tout tout il y avait plus
rien chez moi vous en Avaz pleuré je
suis sûr ouais franchement c'était dur
ah vraiment ah oua vous AES dit je m'en
débarrasserai jamais ça a duré combien
de temps ça a duré un peu moins de 2
mois ouais quoi 2 mois de punaise en
fait pendant de mois on se dit qu'on
peut pas aller chez les gens ah punaise
parce que ouais c'est c'est le
motaise mois punaise franchement un truc
de fou ouis on peut pas aller chez les
gens mais non on va pas chez les gens
parce qu'on sait pas en fait on vit dans
des dans des boîtes donc j'avais acheté
des sacs que je fermais hermétiquement
on avait le droit à C vêtements par
ouais et ces sacs là je les mettais dans
des boîtes qu'on fermait et dès qu'on
rentrait on mettait tous nos vêtements à
laver à 60° et tout ça on les mettait
dans des boîtes et en fait on jonglait
avec les cinq vêtements qu'on avait et
quand j'ai trois bébés c'est un peu dur
ah ouais TR béb CIT piqué les bébés non
pas du tout mais j'ai j'ai retrouvé une
punaise sur mon bébé qui avait même pas
un an et sur son body blanc et en fait
là même aujourd'hui dès que je vois une
petite trace noire par terre ouais mon
œil est aguéri je regarde de fou ah
ouais vous êtes maintenant vous êtes
aguéri à la Puna chasseuse de non mais
c'est non mais pour enfin pour la petite
histoire là j'étais avec une de vos
collègues qui avait un truc dans les
cheveux un tout petit truc noir et en
fait on a tous des pou dans
l'équipe non mais elle m'a dit pourquoi
tu me regardes en fait j'ai pris elle
avait une une toute petite peluche et je
lu dit mes yeux il regardent que ça
maintenant et ça fait 8 mois que j'ai
plus rien quand vous dites que ça a été
un enfer beaucoup de gens qui ont des
punaises de lit n'ose pas le dire ont
honte et tombe dans la dépression pour
ça j'ai pas du tout voulu faire ça
d'accord vous vous avez exprimé tout de
suite j'ai vérité qui en a déjà eu ici
la vérit en fait tu en as eu g je pense
pas mais j'ai des doutes sur un Matel
j'ai des doutes je P à table g non non
je pense pas mais alors pour tout vous
dire pour tout vous dire j'ai acheté de
la poudre la fameuse poudre là voilà ça
marche pas ça j'eni alors un gel non
c'est pas un gel tu sens j'ai mis non
j'ai mis de la poudre parce que je il y
a un endroit où je me demande s'il y en
a pas mais dans ces caslà moi très vite
ce que je fais s'il y a un truc souillé
je jette ou après la vrai la vraie
question moi à 5 6000 € pour éradiquer
je pense que j'habite avec les punaises
moi je il y a plein de gens qui vont pas
mettre 5 moi je vous dis j'ai j'ai eu
des piqûes sur le bras et tout ça c'est
pas grave mais je me suis réveillé
j'avais des piqûes Près de l'INE là on
se dit là non franchement non pourquoi
ça prend des proportions incroybl parce
qu'il y a les Jeux Olympiques qui
arrivent ou et tous les touristes que ce
soit pour les Jeux olympiques ou
ailleurs se disent ils ne veulent plus
venir à Paris parce qu' que c'est
infesté de punaise donc le tourisme on
prend un gros coup pourquoi on dit parce
que là on en rigole mais je vous dis
trucou par que il a de Mos en moins de
gens qui veulent venir million
d'intervention antipunais ont eu lieu en
2022 soit 200000 de plus en un an un
foyer sur 10 a été confronté au punais
de lis ces 10 dernières années cette
prolifération c'est des récentes très
fortes chaleur la hausse des
déplacements voyage la mondialisation la
hausse de consommation de seconde main
et c'est vrai que ça pose des problèmes
gilet bien sûr la presse américaine
commence à nous fustiger en disant faut
surtout pas aller là-bas on
a quand mêmeé au
étatsunisid c'est le chameau qui se
moque du bossu ouais il commence à nous
fustiger les Européens se demandent si
c'est bien sérieux de venir aux Jeux
Olympiques donc il il commence à y avoir
une paranoïa et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement la ville de Paris veut agir
le gouvernement Paris
veir enfin agir c'est sûr qu'il il
demande un plan national Olivier ver a
réagi là-dessus maintenant c'est une
affaire d'état en France après moi
c'était c'était il y a 10 mois comme ça
mais quand j'ai prévenu mon syndique le
syndique n'a rien fait hein il s'en
foutait mais royalement je nai même pas
eu un appel même pas un remboursement
rien ah non rien rien j'ai ça veut dire
en fait j'en ai eu pendant donc un mois
et demi de de traitement d'accord après
j'avais plus rien pendant 1 mois puis
après j'en ai vu trois petites comme ça
il faut savoir que la punaise peut ne
pas manger pendant 20 mois 20 Mo ou elle
fait le ramadan ouais
[Rires]
peut-être ce qui veut dire que tu crois
qu'elles sont qu' que tu as éradiqué le
problème et puis elles ressurgissent 20
mois après quoi ouais mais si le voisin
il a des punaises ça venir al toi tu as
mis 5000 ou 6000 balles et si le voisin
il il met pas 6000 balles tu vois estce
que le voisin peut-être que tu lui
envoyer des plusaises aussi au vois bah
oui mais alors moi je l'ai vu vraiment
très vite et et donc donc voilà m et
comment c'était sur votre corps c'était
vraiment des boutons de moustique qui
grattent vraiment beaucoup plus qu'un
bouton de moustique ouis des trucs c'est
c'est comment c'est c'est comme ça ouais
c'est c'est des petits boutonsou moi je
vous dis moi je suis allé moi je vous
avais raconté j'étais allé dans un hôtel
vraiment un bel hôtel chic voilà j'étais
avec un pote on a dormi tout bien tout
honneur c'est Jérôme je dire rien à voir
voilà je mche pas de ce P là il mange à
côté de moi parce il dort à côté de moi
si on avait un tournoi de poker ou pas
et lui je vous dis le matin il se
réveille il est piqué de la tête au pied
il est tout rouge moi j'ai rien lu je
dis c'est faute tu as pas de chance tu
vois non mais c'est vrai et Ben et et
voilà et donc c'est parti assez vite
hein de TR jours après il lu restait
juste deux tris voilà oui mais ça veut
dire cyil par exemple typiquement que
vous auriez pu en rapporter dans vos
bagages de la chambre d'hôtel et chez
vous ça non mais c'est sûr oui certains
commencent à se demander parce qu'il y a
bien une origine il y a quelques années
il y en avait pas les punaises de lit
donc certains commencent à se demander
ça va faire peur mais si c'est pas lié à
la Coupe du monde 1998 en France dire
que des gens mais exactement il y a des
analystes très sérieux qui disent que
les gens sont venus de tous les pays et
que l'expansion des punaises de lit est
concomitante et qui dit ça des analystes
très sérieux c'est une théorie les
punaises de lit seraient venu à
l'occasion de la Coupe du Monde sûr que
c'est pas con tout court je vous promets
que non et du coup le risque des Jeux
Olympiques serait que des
gens oui c'est pour ça je dis vont bah
c'est c'est c'est effectivement vous le
disiez les vêtements deième main mais
c'est les voyages les transports donc
pourquoi si a les punelles elles sont
elles sont dans les avions dans les
valises c'est ça c'est pas sur le corps
c'est dans les bagages c'est ça ouais
c'est ça non elle est sérieuse mon
analyse on dirait pas euh les punaise de
lit impacte tellement la vie des
Français que l'État choisit de prendre
ce sur à bal cor il a mis un numéro a
été mis en place pour les punaises de
lit c'est un truc numéro 086 706 865 non
mais c'est bien beauon un numéro mais
sis aident pas à financer le la
désintégration des punaises ça ser par
contre vous app com V faire les gens
pour payer non mais il va peut-être
falloir aussi que les assurances se
mobilisent parce que vous avez payé 5000
€ mais comme le disait tout à l'heure
Raymon c'est vrai qu'il y a plein de
gens qui pourront pas payer si les
assurances ne Pasi en charge j'imag ou
ou non rien rien mais après il y avait
il y a plusieurs tarifs je dirais et il
y en a un où j'ai fait ramener un
deuxième chien et là ça m'a coûté
beaucoup plus cher que le premier mais
il faut savoir qu'il est pas venu 15
minutes il est venu pendant 2h3 il a
retourné toute toute toute ma maison
tout le le ch
avec ses PES com Arve le maître il
enlève tout ah ouais et puis il fait
sentir le chien et si le chien à bois ou
il s'assoit c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose et c'est de là qu'on a il a trouvé
en fait des des des restes comme ça de
punaise dans ma valise que j'avais
ramené il y a 4 mois avant quoiou par
que si le chien s mon slip moi je peux
dire ça va
être il reviendra pas une seconde fois
qu'est-ce qu' on parle on parle d'un
logement sur 6 infesté en France c'est
énorme un logement sur 6
en France aujourd'hui le gouvernement
réunit les opérateurs de transport parce
que le phénomène est en ha Terri plus
personne
peuter j'aiti
idé on sait que c'est toi merci en tout
cas d'être venuir c'est truc de fou
merci et j'espère que dirait plus jamais
Puna